[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport nous sommes de retour
après un bon mois d'absence pour cause
de ryder cup mais comme le dit l'adage
plus c'est long plus c'est bon et mes
chroniqueurs ne vont pas me contredire
ils sont trois autour de cette table et
ils vont donner le meilleur d'eux mêmes
comme d'habitude je vous propose de les
a présentés aujourd'hui sur le thème
d'halloween vu que nous sommes en plein
dans cette période présentation en
musique s'il vous plaît on commence à ma
droite ses accélérations sur la piste du
vélodrome la semaine de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines font froid
dans le dos à tous les observateurs
petit grand le dracula du club de vélizy
78 de retour pour le jouer un mauvais
tour dans cette émission le capitaine
eyene dujarrier nous fait le plaisir une
nouvelle fois d'être présent sur cette
émission beaux-arts michael alors est ce
que c'est vrai est ce que vous faites
peur tous les observateurs n'en posent
nous attendons ce qui me connaissent par
contre les nouveaux oui parfois je leur
fait peur puisque je ressemble pas du
tout un sprinteur puisque je suis tout
fin et une fois qu'ils ont goûté à mon
double sprint où il a maintenant après
il en effet sur ce moment là ils ont
peur mais après ils sont habitués à voir
ce qu'il dit c'est d'ailleurs cette
vertu d'une scène dure qu'elle couve au
passage à gauche musique les dents de la
mer l'exorciste shining paranormal
activity des films qui font peur mais
pas autant que les soufflantes à la mi
temps de ce coach hors du commun
l'ancien entraîneur du plaisir
rugby-club jour miss la légende
le mythe est avec nous pendant une heure
aux gens bonjour mais qu'at elle
alors est ce que c'est une légende ou
pas c'est soufflante à la mi-temps de
coach jean-louis sinon on
c'est le sujet les jeunes dans la je
suis comme tout le monde je remet les
choses en place quand il faut qu'elle
soit mise en place puis ça dépend de
l'humeur aussi des fois et du
comportement de l'équipe mais bon des
fois ya du bon et du monde il ya du bon
et du moins bon et plus c'est long plus
c'est bon en famille n'a à ma droite
musique s'est réparti sont aussi
tranchante ce que la lame aiguisée de
jack l'éventreur
quand on est face à lui au duel nous
sommes face à un véritable cauchemar
celui que l'on surnomme le gladiateur
dans cette émission pierre chevaillier
du rugby-club de versailles nous fait
une nouvelle fois l'honneur de venir sur
sa démission
bonjour pierre ça lui il ya une forme de
bonheur d'aller vous pleine forme
une rentrée qui s'est très bien passé on
va en parler et on trouve près à prêt à
ferrailler à avec mes camarades vous
avez aiguisez vos l'homme avant
d'arriver tout à fait le glas des prêts
invention il ya gens en face de vous
ayez à côté de vous nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de baseball les cougars de monti
le bretonneux ont perdu en finale de
playoffs
nous ferons également un focus sur le
club du rugby ch de versailles qui se
porte très bien dans le championnat de
division honneur mais avant de
développer à ces thèmes on va parler
cyclisme dans ceux ci ont parlé sport
on commence donc par du cyclisme une
étape de coupe du monde était organisée
du 19 au 21 octobre vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
français qui espérait briller devant
leur public ont déçu pendant la
compétition
ils n'ont remporté qu'une médaille
d'argent en vitesse par équipes à
grégory baugé sébastien vigion et
michael d'almeida et deux médailles de
bronze avec adrien garrel en scratch et
benjamin thomas sur l'omnium on écoute
le directeur technique national
christophe manas quelques quelques
regrets on était à domicile on espérait
peut-être avoir des résultats des
meilleurs résultats on a tenté
du genre de les sportifs sont sortis
assez rapidement
dans les manches de qualification dans
quelques regrets une compétition
difficile également pour mathilde de
gros la pépite du cyclisme français âgé
de 19 ans a été éliminée du keirin alors
qu'elle avait obtenu le titre européen
lors des derniers championnats d'europe
la sportive a également échoué en
vitesse individuelle avec une quatrième
place au sprint mais la championne
relativise on les écoute mais c'est
plutôt prendre les points positifs
regardez toutes les erreurs tactiques
que j'ai fait pour pouvoir aller mettre
en oeuvre justement dans une semaine à
toronto
donc pour l'instant la question sur ce
thème faut-il déjà tirer des conclusions
en conclusion après cette première étape
de coupe du monde vous votez oui non
vous êtes unanime à l'argent du suivant
non non je dis non pourquoi parce que
c'est une étape une étape c'est le match
de la coupe du monde
bon donc c'est comme commun dans la
dèche championnat c'est ils ont perdu un
match mais après les dés sont pas jetés
pourrait donc tout le monde tout sportif
qui se respecte peut avoir une contre
performance c'est le cas sur sept
matches là après je pense quand même que
ça ne remet pas en cause la qualité des
sportifs que nous avons cette discipline
c'est tout pour moi vous êtes d'accord
avec jean complètement surtout que
je les français quand même vous voulez
quand même des médailles sur cette étape
de coupe jeunes alors qu'ils étaient à
domicile il faut le rappeler
le gros point positif que je que je
ressors de cette coupe du monde c'est le
super chrono de greg baugé sur le
premier tour de la vitesse par équipes
il est repassé en dessous de 17 5 qui va
faire un bond de 17 4 donc ça c'est
quand même un bon ou un gros point
un gros point fort parce que c'est vrai
que ça faisait quelques années qu'on
galère est sûre le sur le démarreur donc
là greg grecque revient revient fort sur
sur ce poste ensuite sébastien vie j'ai
fait quand le troisième chrono dans le
4ème ou 5ème chrono du de la
qualification du 200 m avec un très beau
9,6
pour moi ils sont ils sont au niveau
voilà après ça s'est joué à des petits
détails il se fait il suit disqualifiée
en quarts de finale alors qu'il était
voilà lé des portes étaient ouvertes
pour la pour la demie donc ben quand on
est en demies à 3 trois chances sur
quatre d'avoir d'avoir une médaille
il était quand même très fort même si
l'adresse est née la vraie scène était
était impressionnant sur sur ce week-end
donc voilà il ya il ya plein de choses
positives qui se sont
et ensuite voilà des décisions
arbitrales qu'on pas été en notre faveur
et c'est pour moi ça s'est joué
simplement à des détails pour avoir pour
obtenir de meilleurs résultats en termes
de médailles
maintenant en termes de performances
l'égalé des allez les filles étaient là
pour revenir à mathilde autant de
médailles en termes de performance
atteint des performances chronométriques
en termes de performances en temps même
en termes de même en intentions parce
que j'ai vu des choses qui ont été
faites sur les courts de peloton et est
quand même on sent que l'ailé il avait
l'envi qu'ils avaient les moyens ensuite
voilà quand vous êtes sur une course de
pau ton il ya 24 gars sur vous n'êtes
pas tout seul vous avez beau avoir
l'envié parfois
parfois c'est un peu plus compliqué et
donc là moi ça je l' ai vu je les ai
ressenti il y avait il y avait vraiment
une bonne dynamique sur dans l'équipe
maintenant voilà pas de bol
des mauvaises décisions je pense à je
retrouve son prénom mais à gênant de qui
qui passe à la corde alors que jamais
elle doit passer à ce moment là parce
qu'il n'y a pas de danger sur sur
l'élimination
elle se fait éliminer parce que vous
n'avez pas à passer à l'est pas passé la
meilleure tactique les erreurs des lois
de mauvaises décisions donc donc voila
moi pour moi c'est plutôt un bilan
positif ya pas de y'a pas l'inquiétude
chercher la pièce que pour vous il faut
s'inquiéter quand même quand on voit des
disqualifications d'un sébastien vigier
tapha des qualifications c'est sa
qualifiation voilà et les mathilde de
gros également qui et qui rétrograde et
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on peut en
penser finalement est ce qu on peut être
inquiet quand même pour cette équipe de
france nous on en parle suffisamment ici
je pense que c'est une affaire de cycles
cyclosportifs genola rappeler celle une
saison c'est long
que ce soit et mais plus c'est bon comme
vous l'avez peux me rappeler
il ya il ya des scénarios qui s'écrivent
d'une certaine manière au début ou à la
fin
la c1 c'est un démarrage difficile comme
vous l'avez cité mais mais il ya encore
pas mal de pas mal d'occasions de se
refaire ça permet de se jauger un petit
peu si je si je suis anne a priori c'est
les français sont là dessus relais sur
les performances mais ils sont tombés
sur meilleurs qu'eux à ce moment donné
là donc on me relaxer simplement
simplement les les lois les lois
empirique du sport une série une série
qui démarre pas forcément d'inquiétude
parce que parce que les différents
champions et championnes semble lucide
sur leurs performances et sur leur
prestation donc à suivre à suivre pour
la suite mais en tenir compte pour la
suite
alors je vous en je me sens pas vraiment
acquis autour de cette table pourtant
quand même il n'y a pas une victoire en
sprint depuis quatre ans en coupe du
monde et c'est tant chez les femmes
quand même genre finalement vous n'êtes
pas inquiet mais quand même quatre ans
sans victoire
oui mais sans préparation donc pas parce
que là ils n'ont toujours pas gagné que
que faut jeter le l'eau du bain avec le
bébé
61e yann l le problème du sprint
c'est que ça commence à faire long quand
même oui mais il ya plus deux épines
nations dominantes comme il ya pu y
avoir il ya certaines certaine époque
on voit son voile et les nations arriva
a brillé pendant deux saisons avant
avance hégémonie beaucoup plus longue
je vois bien de quoi vous parlez la
france a été ultra dominatrice dans les
années florian rousseau avec et florian
et puis après on a enchaîné avec un
autour de man et puis et puis et puis
laurent gané maintenant le turnover est
beaucoup plus rapide
quand les gars il va être bien sûr deux
trois saisons c'est déjà très très très
très très très bien et c'est la raison
pour laquelle les anglais eux créer des
cycles encore plus long parce que la
seule chose qui les intéresse ce sont
les jeux olympiques et je dirais que il
laisse presque les miettes les miettes
aux autres pendant les pendant les
années pendant les pendant les trois
années où il ya où il ya palais où il
n'ya pas les jeux donc
donc voilà c'est vrai que c'est une
soirée vitesse par équipes les néo z ont
été très bons pendant pendant quelques
années et là on voit que les que les que
les hollandais près de près de
leadership et même dans ce cadre là et
bien il arrive à être champion du monde
mais ils ne sont pas champions d'europe
donc voilà c'est ça montre bien la
difficulté et la densité et le fait que
tout se jouait à des à des tout petits
détails on a vu une très belle poursuite
des anglais qui c'est qui s'est soldé en
moins de dix tours parce qu'ils ont fait
une erreur au démarrage et
et ben voilà en finale et pourtant ce
sont les anglais et ben même là il
arrive encore à faire avec des arrêts à
faire des erreurs et a passé à passer à
côté donc voilà pas de pas d'inquiétude
tout ça c'est du rodage les français
même s'ils n'ont pas les résultats sont
toujours parmi les meilleures nations
sont toujours sont toujours là oui bien
sûr on est deuxième on est 3e on est on
est pas toujours mais on est champion
d'europe
on était champion d'europe avec match
d'euros et puis non aux cabines mais
aussi en vitesse il ya et km par exemple
avec quentin lafargue
donc voilà papa cette année mais les
années précédentes donc voilà il ya des
titres il ya des choses qui sont là il
ya des mais voilà il faut tout puisse
être mis en place sur les bonnes sur les
sur les bons sur les bons événements
alors j'aimerais maintenant qu'on
revienne sur mathilde de gros pierre
chevalier est ce qu'il n'ya pas trop de
pression autour de cette fille si
évidemment 19 ans elle est championne
d'europe forcément l'attend au tournant
dès la première compétition à domicile
et finalement ce plan on va le dire
clairement oui si je me souviens bien
signer c'est une c'est une jeune fille
qui vient d'un autre sport qui qui n'a
pas vraiment ce que l'on va du basket
voilà on en avait parlé ici
dans la dans l'aspect reconversion est
là elle manque évidemment de je pense
donc d'ancienneté d'ancienneté dans le
dans ce sport dans ce sport exigeant en
revanche cessé
c'est une pépite et en france on a
effectivement tendance à mettre beaucoup
d'attenté beaucoup beaucoup d'enjeux et
de pressions sur l'année sur les jeunes
championnes au champion parce que on n'a
pas tant que ça donc quand y en a eu qui
se présente effectivement on a beaucoup
d'attentes
en revanche laissons lui le temps de
d'exploser d'exposer dans ce sport est
là elle a priori un certain nombre
d'atouts un mental un mental qui va bien
elle me paraît elle me paraît aussi
fraîche et et lucide sur la partie sur
la partie performance donc donc oui oui
elle se plante on avait peut-être trop
d'attentes trop d'attentes pour le
démarrage laissons lui le temps
d'exposer dans ce sport jean vous êtes
d'accord avec pierre oui tout à fait
bien sûr elle est jeune elle est jeune
mais on voit pierre parler de la
lucidité
elle est totale parce que elle et elle a
fait des heures elle a pris conscience
et ça va faire grandir ça va la préparer
et à la 19 ans donc forcément ce sera
une forcément ce sera une grande
championne mais les animer le temps et
nous c'est le mal français
dès qu'on a déconné des graines de
sportifs de grands sportifs
on voudrait tout de suite que ça explose
tout de suite qu'on soit en haut de
l'affiché mais non mais non il faut mais
des fois il ya des doués mais des doux
et on a très très très très peu bon ben
il ya des gens aussi qui sont faits pour
ça qu'ils sont légèrement de nouer mais
qu'il faut quand même du travail pour ce
niveau là puisque yann l'a dit le le
niveau se resserre de plus en plus et
que les sièges éjectables
ça va beaucoup plus vite donc laissons
lui le temps mais je pense qu'elle a
elle a tout pour réussir
alors il ya quand même des satisfactions
sur cette étape de coupe du moins ils
benjamin thomas qui a remporté une très
belle médaille de bronze en étant un peu
à court de forme
on les écoute on va retenir le positif
voilà le petit personnel la troisième
place sur l'omnium ya celui des grandes
sensations voilà c'est
ça faisait longtemps que j'avais pas
j'avais pas vibrer avec le public et
c'était vraiment un grand moment et
là on en avait ça fait du bien d'avoir
des compétitions en france chez nous
quoi yann c'est une super performance
quand même pour germain thomas une
troisième place bien sûr oui qu'il est
allé chercher qui est allé chercher
brillamment
mais je dirais c'est un petit peu je lui
disais en introduction tout à l'heure il
est allé la chercher à la motivation le
public l'a aidé sur certains sprint et
puis il a bien vu la course il a pris
les tours au bon moment sur le sur le
sur la course à points donc voila
c'était c'était une très belle course
c'est un grand plaisir de le voir il y
avait une belle domination aussi parce
que alors donnez moi c'est un espagnol
qui gagne il ya une omnium mai mais il
était il est très très très costaud sur
le sur le début de la course aux points
et donc voilà c'est c'était très sympa à
voir
à voir dernière question sur cette
thématique la justice oublie juste un
exemple je voulais juste intervenir sur
mathilde je pense qu'il ya un biais de
petites erreurs sur les trois jours elle
a couru les trois jours et il aurait pu
nous avait expliqué avant début de la
compétition que c'était maintenant les
nouvelles normes pour les grandes
championnes
oui d'accord mais ça va faire du bruit
mais prennent ces cas-là 19 ans oui il
faut rien pour les trois jours mais pour
l'instant elle n'a que 19 ans il faut
encore tête nue c'est un petit peu de
temps j'ai vraiment senti sur les deux
manches de keirin la demi finale et la
finale qu'elle manquait de jus et et
elle n'a pas fait cette prime comme si
c'était son choix peut-être je ne sais
pas je ne remets pas la turquie en cause
mais voilà nous prenons le temps alors
dernière question sur cette thématique
est ce qu'il faut refaire une
compétition comme celle ci au vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
il ya quand même eu trois plus de 300
athlètes 3000 spectateurs en moyenne au
vélodrome nationale oui ou non
rapidement
oui pas tous les week-ends parce qu'il
faut se montrer le là aussi on en a pas
on a souvent parlé ici le sur la
communauté d'agglo et en ile de france
plus il ya des événements sportifs de
cette envergure là dans tous les sports
mieux c'est pour le développement
justement de cet esprit sportif sur le
derrière lequel il court depuis
longtemps pour donner pour donner en
plus du spectacle et du plaisir aux
spectateurs de données de donner aussi
quelques quelques idées quelques
vocations gens aussi pas mieux pas mieux
ok on le voit maintenant une page rugby
dans ceux ci ont parlé ce sport dans le
championnat de division honneur
versailles dans le fini à plus de gagner
les versailles ont engrangé leur
quatrième victoire de la saison en
autant de matches en s'imposant assez
facilement 26 à 9 contre le rc et
paris15 on écoute les réactions on a eu
un petit passage un petit peu un temps
faible en fin de première période on a
remis les bouchées doubles en début le
début de deuxième mi temps et c'est
alors je dirais pas que c'est sans force
elle en affirmant confiance confiance en
nos forces on est au dessus dans le sens
où on a confiance on a confiance en nos
forces et quand on arrive à jouer
simplement on peut arriver à mettre en
difficulté n'importe qui à partir de là
c'est plus facile on est très contents
très satisfait l'engagement dégâts et de
ce qu'ils produisent à l'entraînement
donc on est sur la bonne la bonne voie
pierre on l'a vu sur ces images ils sont
très tactile et oui c'est un sport de
contact rugby évidemment oui alors avec
cette victoire les joueurs de la cité
royale s'envole déjà au classement
l'équipe compte quatre points d'avancé
sur clichy après seulement quatre
journées dans ce championnat de division
honneur
malgré cette place de leader les
versaillais ne veulent pas à s'enflammer
l'excès de confiance en hausse et un
partout dans la vie c'est comme ça dès
qu'on a un peu trop d'excès je pense que
derrière on peut avoir des déconvenues
donc
voilà il faut rester vigilant travail et
bossez continuer parce que bon il ya la
montée en fédérale 3 mais au prix il yal
aventure aussi humaine avec avec les
garçons j'ai encore plein de matches le
premier est le plus important c'est de
faire un premier bloc
le problème lors des quatre matchs de
faire que des victoires on s'attendait
pas à prendre autant de prendre deux
niveaux bonus offensif france surtout
contre les équipes comme rcp 15 étonnant
c'est tout c'est tout bon la question
sur ce thème l'équipe de versailles
était déjà en fédérale 3 votez messieurs
oui oh non abba peut-être non non les
spécialistes disent non moi je ne me
prononce pas moi je voulais juste posé
une question parce que je suis un petit
peu dans cette émission débat non non
non peuls pas mouiller la houle et
comment ils font comment ils font pour
avoir des coupes de cheveux encore
qu'ils tiennent comme ça la fin d'un
match de moi à la fin d'un tournoi de
vitesse j'ai les cheveux qui part dans
tous les sens et les bons produits et un
petit peu de temps dans les vestiaires
ça ça se pomponner c'est en tout cas ça
marche
alors l'équipe de versailles était déjà
en fédérale 3 où vous avez tous répondu
non aux gens pourquoi on donnera la
parole à pierre juste après parce que
sportivement on ne peut pas dire il ya
que quatre journées il ya que quatre
journées quatre points d'avancé c'est
rien du tout c'est une victoire puisque
c'est une victoire simple ces quatre
points et bonifier ces cinq points on
compte pas on peut pas dire à quatre
journées du début qu'une équipe est déjà
et finira première d'autant plus qu'ils
n'ont pas creusé l'écart
voilà on a le classement de sous les
yeux ils ont pas encore creuser l'écart
ils n'ont pas joué clichy qui est à mon
avis
le principal le principal adversaire de
versailles du classement à six points
voilà ils les ont pas encore joué en
opposition directe donc non on peut pas
appuyé sportivement ça se dit pas ça
même même si pour moi là c'est moi
j'engage cette année je vois pas comment
il pourrait pas finir premier de poule
étant donné que vise ont mis les
ingrédients qu'il fallait que ce soit au
niveau recrutement que ce soit au niveau
continuité de 2,2 politique de club donc
bons intérieurs site web
selon vous oui oui c'est un club
structuré le seul petit jeune j'avais
déjà parlé ici de ce petit bémol que je
peux reprocher à ce club ses s'ils
veulent s'ils veulent s'ils veulent
continuer pérenniser et sur leurs
résultats
c'est qu'il arrête de changer
d'entraîneur quoi parce que parce que si
on fait si on fait le bilan de
versailles sur les cinq dernières années
je crois qu'il doit encore aller où les
cisailles et le lavoir quatre
entraîneurs sur six en quoi donc là là
là pour la continuité d'un club et d'un
groupe c'est compliqué de changer de
discours et de jeu le système de jeu
tout le
quasiment tous les ans mais on souhaite
en tout cas au nouvel entraîneur de
rester un peu plus longtemps que j'avais
un nouvel entraîneur est très bien je le
connais bien
il est très bien et surtout ils
s'appuient sur un groupe qui est qui et
qui est déjà bien en place
collectivement avec un quorum encore du
recrutement à des postes où ils étaient
un petit peu encore encore faible donc
pour moi je vois pas qui va pouvoir les
arrêter et finir premier axe et accéder
à la troisième division
alors pierre contexte plus
avertissements voilà si j'essaie une
averse et à des sites us et une histoire
de contexte et il ya eu deux
avertissements ou un deuxième un
deuxième actuellement les gens le
disaient il ya une là il ya une
recherche de continuité sur la partie
sur la partie sportive ce que le ce que
le bureau du club et la direction du
club met en place c'est ça s'inscrivait
sur un cycle de trois ans c'est à dire
que on a repris le club avec les
historiques la famine r9 depuis depuis
trois ans va un peu moins de trois ans
maintenant avec un objectif de remonter
en fédérale 3 sur les sur les trois
années le style le staff sportif devait
s'inscrire dans la durée et c'est pour
ça c'est la réponse négative c'est pour
ça qu'on a dû changer changer l'année
dernière deux d'entre elles d'entraîneur
jean le rappeler
on sait maintenant on a misé sur un sur
un quatuor d'entraîneurs en première et
en réserve qui va justement construire
est destinée sportive du club pendant
pendant les trois quatre années à venir
et plus si affinités c'est vraiment
l'objectif actuel le contexte donc c'est
une restructuration du club et puis
justement une mise en avant de la
formation parce qu'un des objectifs en
plus de la rend plus de la montée en
fédérale 3 c'est d'avoir un maximum de
joueurs formés au club dans les équipes
seniors dans les années à venir
et ça commence à donner puisque on a on
a des juniors montant de l'année
dernière qui avait fait une très belle
saison une très belle saison en
championnat de france notamment au
tombant uniquement contre le champion de
france quatre ans m on a des juniors qui
vont qui sont entre qui sont en première
et en réserve cette année donc là la
politique de formation donne donne du
fruit et donc sportivement le contexte
et jeu c'est vrai que c'est une poule
qui est abordable je suis pas dire
facile mais c'est une poule qui est
abordable sportivement plus que plus que
la poule qu'on avait l'année dernière
avec avec quelques grosses cylindrées
mais des équipes qui sont qui sont à
notre portée pour l'instant le contexte
le contexte nous avons raison là de ce
côté là il faut aussi un facteur chance
c'est d'avoir justement de tomber dans
cette poule plutôt que dans l'autre
poule honneur qui est aussi un petit peu
plus relevé et où ça va ferrailler ça va
ferrailler dur notre objectif c'est de
finir premiers de premier pool pour
pouvoir accéder directement à la
fédérale 3 et les deux avertissements on
en a eu un an déjà
c'était le premier match d'ailleurs et
c'est tombé c'est tombé idéalement dans
la saison c'était le premier match à
l'extérieur à monter son château et on
gagne le match à la toute dernière
seconde par une pénalité et après avoir
fourni un match relativement dégueulasse
assez laid dans mes mais dans
l'engagement dans l'engagement ouvrant
mentale versailles passe le deuxième est
relativement ça serait maintenant de ne
surtout pas prendre la grosse tête et de
ne prendre personne de haut
on n'est pas arrivé la saison est encore
longue on le rappelle suffisamment ici
il ya du chariot à vous réveiller cette
émission je sais pas s'il était électeur
en revue et en asie c'est très difficile
à part alors le fait d'avoir échoué
peut-être l'année dernière alors que
quand même verset était d'en haut du
classement
est ce que c'est un bon avertissement
finalement pour cette saison passée ce
que
tout ce qu'on vient de gérer le regard
vraiment extérieur 13 par rapport au
rugby tout simplement la seule chose que
je vois c'est que et par rapport à ce
que pierre vient nous dire c'est qu'ils
ont battus montesson il est en effet
c'est certainement une bonne chose parce
que même en ayant perdu contre vous on
voit que montesson est quand même
toujours troisième du championnat et
toujours au contact donc donc en effet
là il ya peut-être eu un bon coup de bol
est quelque chose qui surtout que ça
s'est joué sur la fin du sur la fin du
match s'est joué à rien maintenant voilà
tout a été dit puisque ben il faut voilà
ça fait que 4 4 journées tout ce qui est
pris c'est déjà bien l'objectif il faut
rester focus dessus et puis une saison
de rugby c'est long faut croiser les
doigts pas de blessure voilà un c'est
quand même c'est quand même ce qu'est ce
qui est plus le plus important et dense
et sport de contact
c'est quand même ce qui arrive aussi
assez régulièrement donc va falloir
falloir pallier à tout ça
mais voilà bravo pour ce pour ce bon
début de saison
légende rappeler ses rivaux des au
départ on a cette année un effectif
fourni ses rangs mais on a près de 90
seniors pour deux 2 équipes pour le
groupe senior
on bénéficie d'une d'un bouche à oreille
et d'un bouche à oreille positif et puis
d'une des résultats de l'année dernière
puisque l'équipe senior fait un quart de
finale de championnat de france en
honneur donc ça généralement ça ça parle
ça parle des joueurs on a la chance
aussi en ile-de-france d'avoir pas mal
de mutation professionnelle
d'année en année et donc des joueurs qui
viennent frapper à la porte des clubs
dont on parle on a eu cette chance là
l'année dernière d'avoir de faire un bon
bout de chemin avec
avec le staff en place avec les i avec
l'effectif en place donc on a on a un
effectif qui devrait nous permettre de
pallier de pallier à tout à toute
blessure grave
on est venu en espérant évidemment des
êtres est très vite les éviter jean le
coach craignent également la période
hivernale avec justement des blessures
ou peut être une des motivations des
joueurs qui ne viennent pas forcément à
l'entraînement qui rate un entraînement
est ce que c'est un gars est vraiment
charnière vraiment une saison à cette
période hivernale surtout en règle c'est
un rugby en rugby sas et c'est pas que
versailles s'est tous les clubs la
période hivernale en plus elle est
longue
un mois et forcément forcément tout le
monde se relâche un petit peu et avec
les terrains aussi un peu bout avec le
terrain voit les terrains peut-être plus
du seul et que bull je dis que oui c'est
plus le gel que la burundi la boue c'est
pas bien grave la boue rugby c'est le
gel qui fait mal
donc c'est plus c'est plus dans ces cas
de figure qu'on peut risquer des
blessures encore encore une fois on l'a
dit il un gros effectif
après il va falloir rester concentré
parce que forcément mais au fil de l'eau
fil de la saison le plus gros le plus
gros problème trainer c'est de garder ou
son équipe à un niveau supérieur aux
autres et donc un niveau de jeu
supérieur pour pour ne pas perdre quoi
parce que ça va être l'équipe à battre
forcément tous les dimanches mais tout
le monde va vouloir battre versailles vu
que ce sont les leaders et forcément ils
vont être obligés d'être au top tous les
dix vaches et c'est là où c'est
compliqué difficile et c'est pour ça
qu'à quatre journées du début on peut
pas commencer à dire ça y est c'est fait
s'est rapidement parti ce qui est en
train de se créer des petits faits de le
rappeler dans son dans son interview
c'est que c'est aussi dans une aventure
d'hommes une aventure de copains
il ya une très bonne ambiance au sein du
au sein du groupe saignements en misons
mise autant sur l'humain que sur le
sportif est donc là pour l'instant ça
démarre bien la mayo est en train de
prendre et on vise en plus de la montée
en fédérale 3 allée à l'issue des
matches de poule
un petit trajet en championnat de france
et tout ce qu'on souhaite et une
ambiance également on peut le dire
positif dans les tribunes les joueurs du
rcv sont soutenus à chaque match depuis
un an par un collectif d'ultra
versailles est composé d'une vingtaine
de membres
pendant toute la rencontre ses
supporters installés en haut de la
tribune du stade de porchefontaine
n'hésite pas à chanter danser ou encore
à sauter et ils font beaucoup de bruit
regardez
c'est tout au long de la saison va
suivre sur le marseillais le collectif
ultra et en fait on vient voir tous les
matchs supporter les copains tous les
dimanches que ça soit des missions à
l'extérieur c'est fait
maintenant plus d'un an qu'on va créer
l'assaut tous les moteurs d'aller
simplement faire parler avec ce qu'on a
pu voir pendant pendant ce week-end fin
de week-end dernier au vélo 2050 1 dès
qu'il y avait un français qui mettait la
moindre attaque tout le vélodrome était
en ébullition
enfin crier et puis bah cordes c'était
les français qui gagnait pas eh ben les
autres nations il faisait un peu la
gueule et on a vu des hollandais un peu
alpaguer la halle payet public pour va
pour ce faire féliciter simplement parce
que les matches étaient aidés de qualité
donc
donc voilà et c'est vrai que quand on
voit ça c'est chez des amateurs
j'imagine que quand on est sur le
terrain ça doit faire chaud au coeur
parce que et c'est même pas ça doit
c'est ça fait chaud au coeur et ça donne
envie de 2 2 pouces et plus fort et
d'aller d'aller prendre des points pour
pour les copains qui sont en tribunes il
en faudrait plus dans tous les clubs
jean des ultras comme ceux là bas c'est
super heures mais c'est très bien ça
c'est très bien pour y avoir des choses
ont pensé on passe devant de ses ultras
que vous avez côtoyé de près alors oui
c'est très bien pour un pot pour un
groupe pour un groupe ça s'inscrit dans
la continuité de ce que 2,2 selon par
les pierres c'est à dire une aventure
humaine ces phénomènes laon font partie
de sa dette
parce que c'est sur les déclencheurs de
petit petit troisième mi-temps
sympathique et en plus quand il ya les
résultats donc
c'est là c'est une partie de l'avant
turquie et qui est fantastique c'est
j'ai joué j'ai joué pendant ça fait
presque vingt ans je suis au club j'ai
joué devant des tribunes vides qui
sonnait vraiment creux et hélas cette
aventure de du cube donc du collectif
ultra versailles et ça démarre par au
départ des joueurs blessés qui viennent
soutenir leurs potes des copains de
copains des copines de copains etc etc
et ça et ça grossit grossit et désormais
ils sont là à tous les matchs à porsche
fontaine et aux matches à l'extérieur
faut aussi le souligner ce qu'ils font
les déplacements et c'est une ambiance
absolument fantastique il faut pas
oublier qu'on est en rugby amateur
départementales régionales
c'est assez rare pour être notée on a
cette chance fantastique d'avoir cette
pierre à l'édifice qui apporte
effectivement l'ambiance de la
motivation du plaisir vraiment à venir
voir un match de rugby il s'éclate en
tribunes c'est toujours bon enfant
sportif fair play pour pousser les
versailles et mais aussi pour pousser le
beau jeu avec les équipes qui viennent
nous rencontrer au stade
donc ça c'est une des raisons aussi de
la bonne santé du groupe du groupe
français du coup français du groupe
versailles est effectivement de temps en
temps ça fait la recette de la buvette
et sa modération
c'est pas c'est une des les aider leur
animation avec modération
ils sont ils sont ils sont très inventif
très créatif et on l'est on les aide en
fait sur la partie communication et sur
la partie sur la partie agenda et puis
on l'est on les suit on s'assure qu'il
soit toujours aussi nombreux en tribunes
c'est un vrai bonheur alors on va ranger
maintenant les ballons ovales et on
passe à notre rubrique focus on va
parler à baseball
[Musique]
les cougars de montigny le bretonneux
n'ont pas réussi à décrocher le premier
titre de champion de france de leur
histoire les y monte ont perdu ce samedi
c'est le troisième match de leur série
contre auront sur le score de 2 à 0
les couverts pourront se consoler en se
disant qu'ils ont tout simplement
réalisé le plus beau parcours de
l'histoire du club sont également
qualifiés pour la coupe d'europe une
première pour montigny le bretonneux
on écoute les réactions on peut pas
parler de défaite attendue série vous
disiez malheureux mais c'est vrai qu'on
s'attend toujours une finale on aime la
gagne et quand on joue c'est parce qu'on
ce qu'on dit souvent une finale ça se
gagne
là on a vraiment fait notre maximum on a
été on a été le plus haut possible et
plutôt que malheureux on est vraiment
heureux de ce de ceux de ce résultat
en tout cas de sur la saison donc je le
disais précédemment les couleurs soul
donc qualifié pour la coupe d'europe une
première pour montigny le bretonneux la
question sur ce thème les cougars
peuvent-ils avoir des regrets d'avoir
perdu en finale
oui oui partager on fait un petit duel
entre jean yanne jaliya gioria maria les
gens vont commencer à les appeler ici
c'est parti c'est parti alors mais voilà
je suis partagé pourquoi parce que des
regrets oui on peut avoir des regrets
parce qu'ils ont perdu la finale ça
c'est sûr maintenant l'entraîneur l'a
lui même dit dans le reportage que
c'était que c'était déjà pas un exploit
mais que sportivement être arrivée en
finale
c'est tellement l'aboutissement d'un
travail d'un travail collectif
impressionnant et que bon pour la finale
c'est déjà c'était déjà bien après une
finale c'est un objectif annoncé en
début de saison voilà bah voilà donc
mais atteindre l'objectif c'est toujours
cette hausse est de 7 janvier mais ce
qu'on fixe toujours des objectifs pour
pour syrah syrah aussi rapproché mais ne
pas spécialement les athènes donc là ils
ont atteint l'objectif donc c'est une
c'est bien c'est un positif après là où
je suis mitigé c'est que y'a pas photo
quoi y perdre 3-0 alors ils perdent 3 0
milliards 4 1 dans le premier match 4 à
3 dans le second tour malgré 2 à 0 dans
le troisième
d'accord mais ces trois matches romane
serda normale sur trois donc à
abandonner à la donne et on peut avoir
des regrets oui parce que c'était le
fils à l'école la paire du sessad un
sportif c'est logique après sportivement
ou perdez trois fois les trois parties
sur trois il faut être fou être réaliste
quoi faut être objectif aussi c'est pour
ça que je suis mitigé
yann après jean moi je jouis enfin moi
mon discours illico en effet une finale
c'est fait pour être gagné parce que ben
si on est automatiquement déçus de la
voir de l'avoir perdu
maintenant quand on entend le coach ben
ils sont satisfaits de leur saison
maintenant on peut même pas dire qu' il
faudra tirer les conséquences sur les
saisons à venir puisque ben c'est une
marche qu'ils ont toujours du mal à
aller à aller chercher
c'est pas la première fois que ça leur
que ça que ça arrive de perdre en finale
qu'en demi-finale d'habitude ils ont
gravi ils ont gravi un échelon
supplémentaire
en effet c'est cesser la compétition
c'est de la pression supplémentaire
quand on arrive quand on arrive à la
finale parce que ben il faut et on veut
tous gagner un des la rade leurs
adversaires le voulait aussi
moi je pense que ça joue sur le deuxième
match où ils perdent 4 3 à l'extérieur
je pense que si ce match-là tour dans
leur faveur ça peut vraiment changer la
physionomie du hadj est très serré en
somalie mais mais c'est et voilà enfin
lors la problématique quand on regarde
le tableau se dire qu'ils ont fait les
deux premiers matches à l'extérieur et
ils font le troisième match à domicile
et s'il avait gagné ce troisième match
on aurait eu un quatrième a ralenti
bretonneux et un cinquième à
montigny-le-bretonneux pour départager
les deux c'est quand même dommage
d'avoir deux coups de devoir jouer deux
premiers à l'extérieur et du fait
commentant sur le format du basket ball
par exemple
come on come on plombe il deux premiers
du coup c'est vrai que la dynamique
quand on attaque le troisième
bah c'est pas la même
c'est alors après j'imagine que c'est
des questions de logistique c'est ils
doivent faire deux matches sur une sur
une sur une même journée
quand il y quand ils se déplacent et
puis après quand ils reviennent ils sont
susceptibles d'en jouer dans joué trois
ans fait trois sur le match retour mais
c'est vrai que là je sais c'est un petit
peu c'est un peu dommage de et pour moi
ça se joue sur ce sur ce deuxième match
ce qui a été et qui a été acquis a été à
couteaux tirés et et qui aurait pu
basculer en leur faveur
pierre vous pensez que l'expérience de
ronds à jouer sur cette finale en
sachant qu'au rond avait gagné 14 des 16
dernières finales surtout ici à priori
d'après le classement c c'est le
troisième et quatrième qui vont au final
au délitement premier et deuxième
donc ils avaient le même nombre de
victoires ces noms de victoires qu'on
voit à l'écran 1 et donc seront et monty
bretonneux étaient à égalité parfaite
sur la saison oui donc donc c'est donc
évidemment le sur un format comme ça de
phase finale l'expérience joue jean l'a
rappelé ça a été assez nette
en finale ils vont même pas jusqu'au
quatrième ou cinquième match et donc
c'est oui c'est sûrement c'est sûrement
une façon d'aborder l'événement une
façon d'aborder la finale puisque à
priori montigny est plus habitué aux
demies yen a également rappelé ses deux
ans en arrière montigny-le-bretonneux
était en deuxième division
voilà donc ces petites habitants de quoi
il franchit des étapes
cette nouvelle division demi-finale
deuxième saison finale donc c'est quand
même belle une belle progression et ça
leur servira pour pour la suite on leur
souhaite qu'on leur souhaite successfull
pour mettre le classement et qu'on
regarde quelque chose d'un peu s'il vous
plaît qu'est ce qui est si vous
intéressé n'y a rien qui m'intéresse
mais il faut juste regarder si on
regarde à la sénart au club d'île de
france
montigny club d'île de france savini
club d'île de france c'est depuis qques
club d'île de france
ça veut dire que ces quatre clubs ne
peuvent pas attirer les meilleurs
joueurs de la région quand vous prenez
rouen quand vous prenez montpellier
quand vous prenez la rochelle et il
arrive à drainer au niveau régional les
meilleurs joueurs de l'art
nous on les dispatche sur quatre clubs
différents et il ya beaucoup d'un port
également dans les équipes de baseball
et en plus c'est de l'import mais voilà
ce que je sais ce que je veux dire c'est
ça c'est en ile de france
on joue pas alors bien sûr qu'on a plus
de densité mais on ne joue pas à
à armes égales avec des avec des gros
des grosses ceux des grosses régions ou
alors avec des des clubs importants dans
des dents dans des belles régions voilà
la c1 ce mois là quand je regarde le
classement ça me ça me saute aux yeux
c'était juste ce petit point de voulais
je voulais aborder donc en effet ce que
fait montigny aujourd'hui bah c'est beau
donc plus me lisez les milices anciens
je crois à mon team retenir de toute
façon c'est une chance et c'est comme
dans les autres sports l'ile-de-france a
un pouvoir d'attractivité qui est aussi
qui est aussi professionnel par rapport
avec l'oeuvre à des clubs et des sports
amateurs donc et c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que ça dit lui un petit peu les
talons sur différents clubs mais au
moins il ya aussi un pouvoir
d'attraction assez important on va
passer maintenant à notre coup de
projecteur je vous propose maintenant de
prendre le large dans cette émission le
départ de la route du rhum la course qui
relie à saint-malo à la guadeloupe sera
donné le 4 novembre prochain
parmi elles les participants on
retrouvera un certain louis burton
originaire de rambouillet le skipper
veut terminer dans le haut du classement
sur son bateau à bureau vallée on écoute
j'ai un super bateau on a racheté le
bateau qui a gagné le dernier vendée
globe dans la catégorie imoca
on a grâce à nos partenaires purent
faire pas mal de voile qui vont être
tout neuf pour le départ de la route du
rhum et et puis bal équipe bis racing
qui a préparé le bateau toute l'année
moi j'ai beaucoup navigué dessus
maintenant il ya un plateau de dengue 1
puisqu'il y aura 21 bateaux dans ma
catégorie et dans l'es5 ce serait pas
mal un podium ce serait ce serait une
belle réussite est alors la victoire
n'en parle pas
la question sur ce thème doit-il assumé
son statut de favori parce que
maintenant c'est un favori à louis
burton
on peut le dire oui mais moins nombreux
discours pour l'instant il n'assume pas
il assume pas et non parce que dans le
discours en effet il a le bateau qui a
gagné est ce qu il doit l'assumer quand
même quoi qu'il arrive il doit la chine
pour l'instant il ne la suit pas on fait
le vote
elle doit tout d'abord
débattre pour qu'un petit duel entre
jean et du coup pierre
je pense que c'est ian e c'est justement
statut de favori qui envoie là me paraît
extrêmement improbable dire qu'il ya
tellement de paramètres extérieurs
tellement de tellement de facteurs à
prendre en considération que justement
un statut de favori déjà c'est difficile
à difficile à mettre en place alors à
assumer c'est encore plus difficile donc
je pense que là jusqu'à maintenant il
faut qu'il vous faut qu'ils misent sur
la chanson qui mise sur son entraînement
fo qui mise sur la qualité de son bateau
si ça lui permet d'assumer un statut
qu'on lui affubler ok mais j'en doute un
peu ce que parce que la course au large
dans ces courses mythiques là c'est
c'est beaucoup beaucoup de chance et
beaucoup de préparation beaucoup de
forme physique aussi pour pouvoir
assumer les jours les journées et les
nuits de course donc bon vent à lui
genre mais il a quand même
il a lui-même il a racheté quand même
bateau
bureau vallée ça donc un ancien bateau
d'un mais le cash voilà qui a remporté
d'arriver en et globe
il a en plus ils agiraient rénover ses
liens banque populaire qui avait gagné 1
par bureau vallée ouais il a racheté le
bateau il a juste qu'il a juste changé
la peinture que le parcours de nouvelles
voies alors par contre je tiens à
préciser les jours ci l'avait déjà fait
à deux tours du monde un nouveau bal au
son nouveau bateau nous non mais
forcément il est il est favori
habitations vaut bien tous et des
favoris de ce sport là parce qu'il ya
tellement de 2,2 de paramètres j'en ai
joué si vous fermez là toute façon willy
les villes on a donc fait enfin sauf aux
attaquants avec eux non non mais
forcément il faut il en faut défendre il
ya tellement de paramètres qui rentrent
en jeu dans cette compétition le temps
la chance le facteur chance est énorme
après lui c'est un bon un bon navigateur
il un bon bateau donc forcément il est
favori et là il devrait quand même aussi
comme disait hier au tout début il va le
développer
mais il est vrai qu'en maintenant se
positionner un petit peu pour pour dire
voilà moi je fais partie des favoris je
m'affirme comme hôtel et craignez mois
encore parce que là c'est facile de dire
de rester dans l'ombre
et puis de dire non mais là je suis
encore favori mais si quand même fait un
gros bateau ça touche à jet a mis deux
coups les plus durs de la halle audi
donc 20e en 2010 sur la route du rhum 5e
en 2014
septième du dernier vendée globe
forcément c'est un favori yens
aujourd'hui il a mis les choses en place
pour pouvoir passer les marges
supérieures l'entendre dire ouais une
cinquième place je serais content un
podium ce serait top et une victoire on
en parle j'imagine même pas moi ça c'est
pas dans l'année c'est pas un discours
de
de conquérant j'ai enfin quand on veut
être toujours parti du principe
sciemment vite sur le post sur un podium
il faut viser le titre si on vise le
titre et on a plus de chances d'être sur
le podium
si on vise le podium oui on sera dans
les cinq premiers là je trouve qu'il a
la démarche la démarche inverse je
trouve ça dommage surtout que hilal mais
il a un très bon bateau le meilleur je
ne sais pas mais il a un très bon bateau
puisqu'il a déjà parce que nous avons
racheté d'autres bateaux aussi voilà il
ya les autres on s'y améliorait donc
voilà tout le monde tout mon travail mes
demandes et a demandé à un budget pas
retrouvé sans un pilote de formule 1
français s'il rentre pas puis l'actuel
ticket chez grosjean voilà romain
grosjean demandez lui si on lui fit de
la voiture d'hamilton ci visera pas le
titre ou ci visera pas le podium je
pense que la réponse allez allez allez
cas elle est ferme et définitive
oui bien sûr si j'ai la meilleure
voiture je vise le podium et c'est déjà
des et parce que voilà quand on a le
meilleur outil dans ces sports
mécaniques parce que là oui bien sûr que
commet toujours avoir le bon outil mais
quand on a quand on a les meilleurs les
meilleurs outils bah oui bien sûr qu'on
veut est devant et voilà c'est juste son
discours maintenant il est humble et ça
peu et ça peu comme ça peut quand même
être
rêva pas mais ça peut quand même fournir
de bons résultats par la structure
française sarah detres d'arrivée masqué
et puis de forcément assumer ses statuts
la ligue à 33 ans c'est peut-être le
moment pour lui de s'affirmer
expérimenté fait remonter l'allée les
marins à l'est des marins n'ont pas
d'eau douce mais dur au long cours est
sûre c'est sur ces courses exigeantes se
base sur un certain nombre d'années
d'expérience
alors si en plus il ay là il a un bon
bateau là peut-être qu'on pourra parler
de statut de favori et la différence
aussi avec un vendée globe où il avait
terminé septième une route du rhum c'est
une quinzaine de jours à peu près de
course un bon jour facile d'ailleurs
jean sera au départ je tenais dans
l'échangé le plus beau des médias alors
de changer de thématiques une dernière
info route du rhum louis burton ne sera
pas le seul illinois participer à la
compétition
le versailles et éric bellion 9e du
dernier vendée globe sera à bord de son
bateau comme un seul homme en faveur des
handicapés ils espèrent avant tout
terminer la course puis voilà il veut
pas être terminer premier il veut
terminer la course
voilà un petit et commentaires encore ce
serait autant divine oit sur ces
compétitions au large c'est facile la
pièce d'eau des suisses et un est très
connu pour ses pour ses qualités de 50
c'est ça c'est normal je pense que c'est
parce que le 21ème arrondissement de se
situer autour de la boule ou alors de
deauville et donc du coup on a facilité
quand on vivrait voilà allez allez
passer des vacances là bas
on va arrêter de dire des bêtises mais
non la voile c'est une passion qui pique
un peu tout le monde je pense que quand
on a la chance de pouvoir le pratiquer à
un âge jeune et puis que nos parents
enfin que les parents leur ont montré ce
que c'était voilà quand on est passionné
quelle que soit la région d'origine
eh bien on a envie de s'investir c'est
investir dedans c'est un beau sport est
alors moins là où je voulais quand même
répondre à votre à votre question par
rapport à voile à ce coureur ce
versailles et qui lui souhaite juste
arrivé dans toutes les disciplines dans
toutes les courses quand vous partez sur
un marathon 42 km il y a quinze mecs qui
généralement viennent d'afrique qu'ils
veulent gagner les autres veulent faire
une performance personnelle
chronométrique
et puis après il y à la grosse masse de
file job qui elle veut devenir finisher
voilà donc chacun il prend l'important
c'est que chacun y prennent du plaisir
ce sera un mot de la fin sur cette
thématique on passe maintenant à notre
dernière page la rubrique des bas dans
cette page débat nous allons parler de
golf la ryder cup s'est officiellement
terminée depuis le 30 septembre au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
d la serbie et des trophées terminé à
les organisateurs ont commencé à
démonter les gigantesques structures
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
l'opération devrait se terminer d'ici là
fin novembre ou plutôt la mi novembre
malgré ces tristes images la fédération
française sort aura réussi sa razer cap
au niveau de l'engouement
les chiffres donnent le tournis un
milliard de téléspectateurs plus de 250
mille spectateurs sur les trois jours de
compétition
des chiffres qui donnent donc des idées
pour les années à venir au président de
la fédération française de golf
jean-loup charron en écoute
nous voulons poursuivre cette politique
d'accueil de grands événements pour
montrer et concrétiser toujours
savoir faire français et que la ryder
cup nous a offert et pourquoi pas je ne
dis pas que nous ferons m on pourra y
réfléchir après la ryder cup accueillir
la rivale en féminin et pourquoi pas
retenté d'avoir une nouvelle ryder cup
dans les années à venir le golf dazelle
tine aux états unis va par exemple
accueillir en 2028 une deuxième ryder
cup après celle de 2016 donc rien n'est
impossible la question sur ce thème le
golf national doit-il de nouveau
candidate et c est pour une ryder cup
dans les prochaines années
forcément oui oui oui jean oui oui bien
sûr bien sûr c'est une réussite totale
vous l'avez dit c'est une réussite
totale
le parcours par lui-même il est
magnifique et au niveau de la technicité
haut niveau à tous les niveaux c'est un
beau golf déjà et puis et puis et puis
voilà on a montré on est monté ce qu'on
savait faire un plus haut à gagner donc
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire de plus
tout était bon et les chiffres on
apprendra à polluer que les chronos
annoncé il ya un autre à dire bien sûr
qu'il faut il faut d'ailleurs heureux de
le faire pourquoi pas ce qu'ils veulent
essayer de faire mieux cc américaine il
se fait battre et en plus on a fait les
choses en grand
d'habitude c'est eux qui font de sa de
gland les a battus un petit peu sur leur
propre terrain que ce soit le terrain
sportif et le terrain le tout ce qui
était animation autour donc forcément
on a il faut il faut il faut quand il
faut que je me repose t jan
tout est dit et un petit peu oui mais
quand est-ce que étant donné que le golf
américain dont vous parliez 12 ans entre
les deux ryder cup qu'ils organisent
voilà sa montre et puis que les
distributions aussi sont fait très
longtemps en avance puisque la ryder cup
à 50 on est bein ça fait déjà quelques
années que 2010 2011
voilà qu que vous nous en parler donc
donc en effet on sait donc voilà en
effet il faut candidate est maintenant
pour pouvoir avoir une nouvelle ryder
cup dans une dans une dizaine d'années
mais de toute façon pourra pas aller
plutôt pourra pas le faire le faire plus
tôt mais mais ce sera déjà très bien
et comme tout s'est bien passé puisque
moi-même plus grosse inquiétude c'était
les parkings mais comme tout c'est comme
tout s'est bien passé les
infrastructures ont été très très bien
très bien géré bravo bravo aux
organisateurs d'avoir d'avoir répu
répondre à un événement de cette sortie
hier trois points c'est le premier c'est
qu'il ya un contexte historique depuis
1927 le il ya très peu de parcours ils
joignent à la qu'un seul qui a accueilli
deux fois la ryder cup
donc ça serait déjà ça serait déjà une
particularité de
delà du lieu d'accueil français deuxième
point c'est que sur tous les points dont
dont l'organisation française sur
lesquels l'organisation française avait
un point était avaient un poids était
une réussite hier jean le rappeler c'est
une réussite sur toute la ligne en
termes de spectacle d'accueil d'ambiance
le golf national est fait pour ce type
d'événement se dira qu'avec avec
l'ensemble des buts qui bordent qui
bordent les trous et les féroé c'est c1
c'est un fantastique stadium de golf et
là on l'a vécu on l'a vécu pendant la
toute la semaine de riders c'était une
ambiance électrique grâce
grâce au vent à la culture et au savoir
des britanniques est maintenant
troisième point il ya une à une il ya un
doute il se dit dans les couloirs que le
que la candidature de rome pour
l'accueil de l'art et de la ryder cup
2022 est un petit peu on est un petit
peu en ballottage défavorable le
contexte du golfe en italie c'est moins
200 900 mille licenciés c'est un secteur
qui va pas forcément très bien qui est
pas très en forme qui est à l'ombre
évidemment du football et d'autres
sports majeurs et il se dirait justement
qu'il ya quelques doutes sur la capacité
de la partie italienne d'organiser cet
événement là c'est peut-être ici vu lui
la vague sur lequel on peut surfer en
france qu'il peut y avoir une longue
lutte pour première 2022 voilà c'est
évidemment au conditionnel si jamais il
y avait une défaillance de la
candidature italienne de l'organisation
italienne ce serait de reprendre
reprendre le flambeau
et puis on est on est prêt est prêt à
faire mieux encore mieux si c'est le cas
la cds et les professionnels du sport du
golf en france le sont ou sinon
candidater pour pour nom quelques années
sachant que le calendrier il est figé
jusqu'à à peu près 2000 28 actuellement
dans tous les deux ans en europe
il ya d'autres candidats
il y aura sûrement l'espagne qui
reviendra sur le sur le tapis évidemment
les parcours britannique
mais la france a montré avec le golf
national et la colle ni des d'agglo de
50 ans que qu'elle était capable
d'accueillir et de magnifier un tel
événement avec une ambiance sportive
électrique est fantastique
espérons aussi que ça donne à sa donne à
beaucoup envie de découvrir ce sport qui
peut être fun spectaculaire et
conviviale alors je les ai souvent dit
yann moix mon père à mon père était
marathoniens et s'est mis au golf
tardivement et il m'a toujours dit yann
ne n'essaie pas ne commence pas par ce
que il sait comment je suis que je suis
enfin quelqu'un de passionné quand je
fais quelque chose et il m'a dit tu vas
tu vas complètement accroché et tu vas
donc là je pense à beaucoup de donc tu
peux recommander de ne pas de ne pas
essayer de papa maintenant plus tard
plus tard tous non je vais te piquer au
vif piqué par parquet russe mais par
contre
voilà c'est cette phrase que vous permet
même à dix c'est quelque chose que l'on
peut conseiller à beaucoup de gens c'est
à dire des gens qui sont sportifs qui
malheureusement ne peuvent plus
pratiquer leur sport de prédilection
parce que blessures et parce que
beaucoup de sport sont 103 10 ans je
pense je pense au marathon qui au
coureur à pied qui c'est vrai que passer
passer quelques années ça devient
difficile
c'est vrai que dans le golfe ils vont
retrouver un réel plaisir et un réel
plaisir à pratiquer à pratiquer un sport
un vrai beau sport quand pour revenir la
ryder cup du coup de 2022 le d'accord et
pierre c'est le meilleur créneau
possible sahel meilleur chrono possible
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
qui qui est difficile et imaginez-vous
le comité d'organisation rome même si le
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être un peu
compliqué pour eux on leur dit
maintenant les gars vous voulu vous
l'avez pu finalement je pense que ça
peut être très très très très mal
interprété mal interprété et après tout
en étant justifiée par rapport aux
éléments tu que tu nous donnes mais en
effet c'est vrai que l'union organisé et
on vient juste de rien et ça s'est super
bien passé peut-être que oui ce serait
se serait bon créneau et ce serait
énorme de
le revoir quatre ans après quoi quand
même temps rome ne s'est pas fait en un
jour ira gens vous en pensez vous nature
mais oui alors on va revenir sur 2022 si
c'est possible il faut passer après
après statuer que sur 2022
c'est à dire que les éditions précieux
souvenirs suivante qui vont venir juste
après n'ont pas encore été statué pour
l'instant même si on pense que ça va
revenir du côté les îles britanniques
justement où quelqu'un on n'a qu'à se
positionner sur 2030 puisque ça fait 12
ans exactement la même
le même écart pour le minnesota donc
2022 se serait on va dire ce serait ce
serait bien parce que voilà parce que on
a montré ce qu'on savait faire on a le
savoir-faire
c'est chaud encore donc on a
l'expérience
il se sera certainement six et demi
douzaine de ce sera le même comité
d'organisation loc qu'ils ont
l'expérience de ce qu'ils ont fait il ya
peu de temps donc ça ne peut être que
mieux
après si c'est pas de vilaines 2b
position de nouveau sur 2030 très
rapidement vous avez 10 secondes
première réussite de cet événement là
c'est que c'est qu'on parle de golf est
on est on a vu à quel point ça pouvait
en est un événement fédérateur est un
sport fédérateur et s'assied une des
plus importante réussite c'est la fin de
cette émission se retrouve le 7 novembre
prochain pour une nouvelle émission va
terminer par une citation du footballeur
pelé
celui qui pense que la victoire ne
compte pas ne gagnera jamais rien je
vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]